ونحييكم الى التفاصيل مع تصاعدي توتر بين
الولايات المتحده والصين على ازمه تايوان
التي تهدد باشعال الحرب بين القوتين
العظميين يرى مراقبون ان الحرب مع الصين
ستكون مختلفه عن اي حرب واجهها الامريكيون
من قبل محللون عسكريون غربيون يرون ان
التحديات التي تواجه الولايات المتحده
خطيره في ظل العمليات العسكريه وغير
العسكريه التي تستعد لها الصين خاصه ان
المخططين العسكريين الامريكيين يفضلون
الحرب التقليديه
روسا المستشار السابق لعدد من الوزارات
يقول في مقال بصحيفه الشرق الاوسط يقول ان
السيناريو العسكري الصيني وحده قد يكونوا
مخيفا اذ انه من المحتمل لن تشن الصين
هجوما جويا وبحريا وسبرانيا خاطفا وسريعا
للسيطره على اهداف استراتيجيه في تايوان
في غضون ساعات قبل ان تتدخل الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها ويضيف ان الصين على مدى
العقدين الماضيين من بناء قدره هائله في
مجال الحرب الالكترونيه مصممه لاختراق
امريكا
والحمقومات الحنيفه والمؤسسات الاعلاميه
والشركات وتلاعب بها وتعطيلها كما يمكن
للصين ايضا تسليحه هيمنته على سلاسل
التوريد وشحنها حينها سيكون التاثير على
الامريكيين عميقا اذ يعتمد اقتصاد
الولايات المتحده بشكل كبير على الموارد
وسلع الصينيه بما في ذلك تلك التي تستخدم
في التطبيقات العسكريه
يتزمن هذا التحليل مع اعلان بيكين عن
زياده انفاقها الدفاعيه وسط دعوات
لتكثيف تدريب الجيش والاستعداد للقتال
وذلك في افتتاح الدوره البرلمانيه السنويه
قدرات الجيش الصيني بالارقام
الجيش الصيني الاكبر في العالم من حيث
العدد والثاني من حيث الميزانيه
هذا العام سترفع بكين ميزانيه الدفاع
بنسبه 7.2%
لتبلغ 225 مليار دولار في اكبر زياده لها
منذ عام 2019
يضم الجيش الصيني في صفوفه مليونين وخمسه
رجل وامراه
تمتلك الصين حوالي 350 راسا نوويا
لدى الصين ثلاث حاملات طائره
تعمل اثنتان منها فقط والثالثه في مرحله
اختبار في البحر لدى الصين قاعده عسكريه
واحده في الخارج في جيبوتي
نناقش شاهد الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
عبر سكايب دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في شؤون
السياسي الامريكيه اهلا بك ومن دبي صحفي
في مجموعه الصين للاعلام اهلا بكم ضيوفي
واسمحوا
لي ان اعكى دكتور عقيل دكتور عقيل لما تصل
انباء كهذه بان الصين اولا تريد او تزيد
انفاقها العسكري بان هناك مطالب داخل
البرلمان الصيني بتسليح الجيش
واستعداد للقتال
هل يمكن القول بان الصراع الامريكي الصيني
قد يكون حربا وشيكه مستقبلا
شكرا لك اهلا استضافه لك ولجمهورك ووظيفك
الكريم
زياده الانفاق العسكري الصيني ليس شيئا
جديدا العام الماضي ايضا زادته الصين هذه
المره زادته ما تزال الفجر بين الصين
والولايات المتحده كبيره لجهه الانفاق
العسكري الميزانيه العسكريه الامريكيه
اكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف الميزانيه العسكريه
الصينيه تتحدث بحدود 700 مليار وثمانين
مليار دولار في الولايات المتحده الفارق
العسكري للولايات المتحده 47 حامل
الطائرات بين مال الصين ثلاثه وحامض
الطائراتها يعني نحن نتحدث عن قائد الجويه
تمشي في البحر
بتصور انه لا يريد الطرفان للولايات
المتحده ولا الصين الدخول في نزاع عسكري
مباشر بمعنى انه تشتبق قواتهما في قتال
اعتقد هذا عقيل سناتي الى الفرضيات ولكن
الاستعداد للقتال ليس او لا يطرح بطريقه
مستمره داخل البرلمان الصيني التسليح
مفهوم تدريب الجيش مفهوم ولكن كلمه ومصطلح
استعدوا للقتال هذا قد ينبئ بشيء معين
يعني صحيحه هذه الدعوات ليست معتاده لكنها
استمرار لحاله تاخد وتصاعد في الخطاب
الصيني على مدى ثمانيه اشهر ربما العامل
الماضي منذ يعني بدء الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه هناك تزامن وهناك علاقه محاوله
الصين اختبار عزم الولايات المتحده
قدرتها على مساعده تايوان على الدفاع عن
نفسها خصوصا انه الولايات المتحده تاخرت
يعني الصفقات السلاح بين تايوان والولايات
المتحده منذ 2016 ولحد الان بلغت 14 مليار
دولار معظمها لم تسلمها الولايات المتحده
لكن بعد الحرب مع اوكرانيا والتصاعد
الخطاب الصيني بازاء تايوان بدات الولايات
المتحده تستعجل تسليم بعض الاسلحه ذات
الطبيعه الدفاعيه وهي
البعض بانه هو الذي دفع الصين كذلك للحديث
بهذا المستوى عن الاستعداد للقتال ما رايك
سيد تشو
ميزانيه تحادف بنسبه 7.2% من العمل الماضي
ولكن هذه الزياده في الحقيقه في شحن مناسب
وكل ومع كل حيث شكلت نسبه النفقات
الدفاعيه 1.2 فقط باجمالي الناتج المحلي
بنسبه الى الاقتصاد الصينيين نسبه قليله
جدا بالمقاراتي مع ولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وفرنسا حيث نعرف ان نسبه
النفقات العسكريه امريكيه تشكل
ثلاثه.5
باجمالي ناتج محلي للولايات المتحده وهي
اكبر اكثر بكثير من النفقات الدفاعيه
الصينيه وفي الحقيقه قد انخفاض نسبه
النفقات الدفاعيه صينيه منذ طرح السياسه
الاسرى وانفتاح على الخارجي نعم والنفقات
هل ما تعدده من ارقام ومن مقاربات بين
الحظر والماضي يعني بان الصين ليست لها اي
نوايا تذكر فيما يخص تايوان
اعتقد بنسبه الى مسات حيوان هي مساله تجذب
انذار العالم في وقت راح ولكن اود ان اؤكد
مرت اخرى في الحقيقه قمنا بمناقشه هذا
الموضوع عده مباراه الا وهي المسار
التايوان هي من الشؤون الداخليه الصينيه
فطبعا الحكومه الصينيه لا تسمح اي بلد بما
في ولايه واحده ان تتدخل في شؤون
الداخليتها فهذا يعني وبدات بتصليحها يقول
مراقبون بانه تصليح مكثف مغير لما سبق من
تسليحات ولكن ابقى معي سيده شو هناك
مقاربه اود ان اطرح عليك دكتور عقيل نحاول
فهمها مع بعض في الواقع المستشار السابق
لعدد من الوزارات الامريكيه تحدث عن قراءه
وكانها تسريبات مغلى وكانه هناك تسريبات
معينه يقول فيها بان الصين قد تشن هجوم
جوي وبحر وسبراني خاطف وسريع للسيطره على
اهداف استراتيجيه في تايوان نفس هذه
الاخبار لو تتذكر معي سبقت كذلك عمليه غزو
روسيا لاوكرانيا وكانت هناك فيما بعد
تداول لاخبار اخرى اكثر تفصيليه هذا
التشابه هل نفهم منه بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تملك بعض
المعلومات الخاصه بامكانيه اقدام الصين
على شيء يخص تايوان
الخطاب الصيني حدثا على مدى السنوات
الدعوه لعوده تايوان وتوحدها مع الصين هذا
خطاب معتاد دائما هذا هو الخطاب الصيني
اعتقد الجديد في المرحله الاخيره انه لهذا
الخطاب نغمه عسكريه حسب التصعيد استعداد
للمواجهه احساس بقرب المواجهه شيء وشيك
يحدث هذا بدا يظهر يعني على مدى ثمانيه
اشهر او سته اشهر
الماضيه هل ستقوم الصين بعمل عسكري ضد
تايوان من دون ان تقوم بشيء يستفز الصين
انا استبعد هذا كثيرا لاسباب كثيره جدا
اولا تايوان مسلحه جيدا تسليحا دفاعيا لن
يكون سهلا على الصين يعني هذه لن تكون
نزهه ايضا الصين ستهدد نفسها تضرب نفسها
اقتصاديا ان بدات حربا مع تايوان لا
تستطيع ان تحسمها بسرعه نحن نتحدث عن خليج
يعني منطقه بحر الصين الج الامور فيها
سبعه تريليونات من التجاره العالميه لا
تستطيع الصين ان تغلق هذه المنطقه وتدخل
في عمليه عسكريه مفتوحه كلنا نعرف ما حدث
بخصوص العمليه العسكريه الروسيه التصور
ثلاثه ايام جاء الغرب دعم اوكرانيا نحن
دخلنا الان في العام الثاني انا اعتقد هذه
السيناريوهات هي السيناريوهات مفترضه
متخيله وربما مجاني بالصيني يحب ان تظهر
هذه السيناريوهات كبالون اختبار كي ينتبه
لرد الفعل الامريكي ولحد الان رد الفعل
الاميركي يتجنب الحديث عن تصعيد عسكري
واعتقد هذا هو الرد الصحيح في ظل انشغال
امريكا في مكان اخر في اوكرانيا
تتفق مع ضيفي على ان كل ما يقال فدخل
الصيني هو بالون اختبار هو جس نبض لا اكثر
ويقول الدكتور عقيل بانه ان فكرت الصين
مجرد تفكير في غزو تايوان فان التبعات لن
تكون سهله فان الموضوع لن يكون سهل لداخل
الصيني اولا قبل العالم
اعتقد اننا لا نستخدم الخصي لان حيوان هي
جزء لا جزء من الصين ابدا وان موته في
تايوان يقترف الموضوع في اوكرانيا لان
يعني حيوان جزء غير جزء عن الصين ابدا
فبالنسبه الى حكومه الصينيه فهي تد او
تايمه الى حل السلميه بنسبه لتوعيه توهيد
البلاد نعم وهذا المبدا
قبل السياسه دوله واحده ونظامين هذا
الرسمي دائما ولكن
الحد الادنى الذي
صينيه ما الذي لن تقبله الصين يعني نحن
نتابع بان هناك زيارات اصبحت متتاليه من
الجانب الامريكي الى تايوان هناك عمليه
تسليح مكثفه وهذا مستمر والصين تقوم
بمناورات تتحدث تصرح ولكن ليس هناك شيء
فعلي ما الحد الادنى الذي لن يقبل صينيا
وعلى اسره قادره ان تتحرك بك
اعتقد هذا يعني الذنب هذا الذنب يعني خطير
بنسبه الى
السياسه الامريكيه لان هذا لماذا يعني
الولايات المتحده داين من تتحدث بحكومه
الصينيه في هذا الامر لان نعرف ان هي الخط
الاحمر بالنسبه الى الصين فاذا استمرت هذه
الفعاليات باستمرار فاعتقد ان جيش الصيني
سيرد عليها بشكل مباشر ايوه بان حكومه
صينيه لم نترك اي فرصه لاستخدام
السلاح لحمايه الثلاثه اراضيها فاعتقد ان
اذا القوه الانفصاليه داخل تايوان مع
تدعون مع الولايات المتحده او دول اخرى في
سعي وراء استقرار فلا بد من الجيش الصيني
ان يرد عليها بشكل عنيف جدا
وضح
ت في متابعه كل هذا اود شكرا
من دبي تشوتشي ونصحفي في مجموعه الصين
للاعلام ومن واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لحضرتك
دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في شؤون السياسيه
الامريكيه